merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france alors on voit bien
que la société américaine est très
crispé très divisée aujourd'hui quelles
sont ces deux amériques qui s'affrontent
oui bonjour et bien d'un côté l'amérique
des républicains à l'aider qui est de la
base électorale de donald trump qui a
fait le plein en 2016 des électeurs
blancs sans diplôme universitaire et
puis d'un autre côté l'amérique
démocrate qui est beaucoup plus urbaine
beaucoup plus diplômées et ce sens
vraiment c2c deux amériques qui
s'affrontent et puis bien sûr les
minorités qui en particulier des
afro-américains qui votent très
majoritairement démocrate attend déjà
connu une présidentielle américaine
s'est tendue selon vous probablement pas
c'est effectivement le la polarisation à
laquelle les états unis sont arrivés et
est vraiment extrêmement tendue y
compris de manière affective de plus en
plus le rejet du camp adverse et
épidermique
il y a dans les années 60 il y avait 3
5% des américains qui ne seraient pas
d'accord pour qu'un de leurs enfants se
marient avec quelqu'un du camp opposé
aujourd'hui c'est 30% des démocrates et
50% des républicains qui verrait d'un
mauvais oeil une telle alliance donc on
voit bien que eux-mêmes dans la sphère
domestique il y a vraiment une
polarisation qui est de plus en plus
grands alors cette présidentielle
ressemble aussi parfois un référendum
pour ou contre donald trump
on a l'impression que c'est un petit peu
l'état d'esprit on sait que le président
américain a été très critiquée sur sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire
oui effectivement la khl à la
personnalité de donald trump est
tellement clivante qui est qu'elles
masquent un petit peu tous les enjeux de
cette élection présidentielle qui sont
très nombreux et de l'avortement au
contrôle des armes à feu
assurance santé à l'immigration il ya
beaucoup d'enjeu véritable est
effectivement la personnalité de donald
trump se oblitère tout cela en quelque
sorte
hier soir les deux candidats ont jeté
leurs derniers efforts dans la campagne
présidentielle
on a suivi bien évidemment les sondages
qui donnent dubaï donnent gagnant on se
rappelle qu'en 2016 ces mêmes sondages
donnent et hillary clinton gagnante
et finalement c'est donald trump qui est
arrivé en tête est ce que l'on peut
faire confiance aux sondages
aujourd'hui les observateurs sont plus
plus lent qu'en 2016 puisque ils ont été
échaudés par ses sept
cette victoire annoncée d'hillary
clinton il faut comprendre que le
scrutin aux états unis est extrêmement
compliqué parce que il se joue état par
état et qu'il suffit d'un petit nombre
d'électeurs dans un état clé pour faire
basculer une élection on l'a vu par
exemple en 2000 lors de l'élection entre
al gore et george w bush
ce sont quelques centaines de voix en
floride qui ont fini par départager les
deux candidats donc les sondages sont
moins fiables que par exemple en france
où l'élection est centralisé l'élection
aux états unis et très décentralisé y
compris même à l'intérieur des états
puisque c'est chaque comté qui organise
des élections
et justement on pourrait d'ailleurs
devoir attendre avant de connaître le
résultat final puisque chaque état un
système de dépouillement des votes à ces
différents mais on l'a entendu un les
américains sont à sont inquiets
notamment à cause de certains
débordements qui pourraient survenir
après le scrutin
est-ce justement une crainte voilà que
dans certaines grandes villes on assiste
à dire les affrontements violents entre
les deux camps se serait pas surprenant
surtout dans cette période entre ce soir
et le moment où le décompte pourra être
finale si l'un des candidats à une
grande avance ce sera peut-être pas trop
un problème messi
le scrutin est serré cela peut
effectivement amener les supporteurs de
trump comme le l'extrême gauche
ah ça a créé des incidents dans les
villes et on voit d'ailleurs que les
commerces et et se protège dents merci
beaucoup
didier convoi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'institut des
amériques